hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the binding of isaac
we got a boss to kill
and also i got a cursed skull what is
that oh don't tell me that's pooping
meat
that's pooping me hey whoa whoa
easy there gertie all right
okay so you move in a semi-predictable
pattern but that doesn't mean that i
just cool your jets there sonny jim
whoa whoa wait whoa wait whoa wait whoa
whoa okay
so he always goes towards me on his
first attack i think
hey yeah yeah so it's better to get him
get him going longitudinally than it is
to go laterally because that
winds up in oh okay all right this is
it's getting out of here
there you go that's what you deserve are
you happy i'm happy okay
speed and range up roid rage good for me
what my what's going on with my face
is that the roids did to me do i turn
into rocky balboa
adrian i'm probably five so i don't
think that applies to me
okay i'm on the toilet oh no
oh no all right get over it all right
caves
so we got a key there what is that
is that a sperm thingy better not be a
sperm thing
little haunt fear him all right
so okay
all right okay all right okay
i could be fine oh no not sloth
it's almost like all the evils or
whatever oh he's being haunted
oh my god he's afraid of me good
maybe that'll teach him and listen well
that was easy
justice may your future become balanced
does that mean what i think it means
again
probably maybe just use it
okay that's a bomb oh whoa hey
oh hey that was cool i like that
no oh you're creepy oh whoa all right
whoa
whoa whoa there sonny jim
back up a step so you're only vulnerable
when you open your freaking face right
just get back just get back okay
what do i do he's not opening up open up
to me man tell me about your childhood
tell me about your mom okay here we go
no no no no how now brown no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no
oh i thought that bat turned into one of
my dudes
my little buddy whoa whoa all right then
oh those guys aren't killable but
there's something rewarding at the end
of that
this doesn't seem very hard oh god not
this again
better be worth it
i still don't know how to open the uh
gypsy's tail curse how many of these
curse things i'm gonna slam into my face
and what good are they gonna do me i
don't know how to use them
i think i don't know i don't even know
how to use it like ah
keep pressing the wrong button how to
use the like uh
the cat head thing the beehive whatever
it was i don't remember
whoa that guy's got two heads maybe
that's advantageous for him somehow
yep okay so that looks like one with two
locks on it good thing i got more than
enough keys
oh boy it's like christmas
kind of ways possibly have a key in it
yay
totally worth it awesome
ah so many keys i love it yeah
am i gonna feel lucky nope okay my
streak continues i'm doing terrible whoa
wait wait wait
no no no no no no no no no no no
no ow come on now just
okay little buddy there we go okay
hey i got so many of these soul hearts
and i'm never going to be able to use
the ones that they're giving me such
that they can actually heal me
okay maybe now i can because i'm getting
careless
really it's getting harder i think but
i'm kind of getting careless as well
all right but anyway continuing on i
ain't gonna lose that's for damn sure
oh okay whoa yeah whoa wait whoa
let me just carve out a little corner
here hey
yay hey yeah you nibble on his brain
there
haunty hey i said one guy red anyway
that just means he's more special
was that fart cloud explosives thoughts
what all right whatever weirdo
okay what is this yep deck of cards
reusable card generator
how do i use it how do i use it
oh space is how i use it oh
okay that that that is cool
what what does that do what'd that do
why'd that teleport me there this is
what the hermit card does
i guess whoa
okay so that brain just exploded and
left me to die okay
okay then and apparently oh there he is
again he's usable once per room
maybe gold gold things
well that would be useful if i could in
any way get those
they look really nice over there as a
decoration whoa
ow okay all right watch watch watch the
corners watch according scott dammit i'm
taking too much
ow i'm getting hit too much no no no no
no no not today i got to go back and get
those heelies
i know they're still there they gotta
still be there
speed down speed down
why speed down okay just give me this
give me this not that
frankly i think the cap might have been
better now that i know how to use it
i don't know how to use it but i'm going
to try wait did i leave
any hearts anywhere else here i don't
think i did i should be fine so long as
i'm careful i just got to be careful dad
be careful come on the fallen what are
you gonna do you goat weird wait you're
the guy that gave me the thing
whoa whoa wait whoa wait whoa wait whoa
wait wait whoa wait whoa buddy buddy
buddy buddy buddy whoa
weirdo okay you both gonna do that weird
thing where you
explode the whole room cuz that i didn't
like whoa you are aren't you
okay okay
i know you just can't you're bursting
with excitement or whatever
flavor something bursting with something
yeah little chubby has appeared in the
basement i don't know what that means
sweet suffering gimpy is that just a
costume
is that all that really is nothing
really beneficial to me besides a
costume
now it's actually getting dicey if i
can't make it i'm going to be very upset
because i got two levels to go got two
levels i got a present a poop
oh no i'm sure she had
not today okay why'd that have to blow
up by me
i gotta start using bombs to try to find
ways out
there's gotta be bonus rooms that i'm
missing i'm oh for
nothing here these fires don't go out do
they
ow okay unnecessary why
stupid fires stupid freaking fires
okay no do not this brain better not get
me killed i
swear
how are you supposed to know it's got to
be a way to know
god bones bones bones bones bones bones
warm
i need more health i was doing so good
in the beginning of the game i don't
know what happened
it's all fell apart yay money
the one thing i need yay
hey look what does this do boomerang
never leave you
what oh okay i get it okay i got it i
got it i got it
okay that makes sense so that means
that i have an item that will never
leave me whoa whoa
hey whoa oh come on with the brain i
hate that brain
that brain's gonna get me killed it's
not fair
what are these things anyway god they're
weird
okay blow this up
open this up i guess that's what i
needed
which
i don't know what's good i don't like
the boomerang it's too tricky
i don't like trixie things this is keep
with fly hive hopefully it'll do me good
down the road
i don't know yeah stupid fires what are
you
what are you pit of suffering wow
well all right then whoa whoa what in
the
what why what was that all about
all right there's a lot of rooms that i
haven't explored yet so i'm gonna
go explore them that's what i'm supposed
to do in the binding of isaac i assume
hello well i can't do any of this except
maybe the top one but i'll save my one
key left
no no no no no no
no no no no none of this creepy weirdo
[ __ ]
kind of kid goes through this i just
flopped like five
yay no no they were so sad that they
just
died whoa
just blow something up useful jeez that
brain i hate it
okay gotta take these guys out from the
back cause hey
my electricity guy i think you can hurt
him anyway though
okay that door better be worth it when i
go through it oh brainy you sack a crap
brainy is such a piece of [ __ ] how do i
get rid of him
i don't want him ah okay
okay he's not that brain i swear i swear
that brain
are we done no not done
ah yeah we're not
just just okay okay all right
this is my last key for this oh god it
was not worth it
yes this game got to get me wait
no okay do i gotta blow them up i gotta
blow them up don't i
okay here we go okay
what's that dead cat nine lives
that's good right that's good
that's really good right nine lives that
means i can die oh god it reduced my
health that two
i don't know what these things do i
don't know if they're good for me to
select that's why i just select whatever
i got
okay bommy actually did something good
there
rather than just screwing me over all
the time i don't have a key for that
i have a key forget
all right last room to check oh god not
you guys
okay that was weird okay i got a key
cool
oh boy die die die die quickly die
efficiently
die die die die die die okay all right
quickly and officially
that's what i like exactly what i like
okay
all right now you guys again
fly hive oh why
the only time i got near you you son of
a [ __ ] you brain are the worst
literally the worst hey
hey was that a happy bomb
mr reusable bomb buddy why do i need
that i already got plenty of bombs
take the fly hive
is going swimmingly everybody whoa
okay i thought there was more to it than
that there is
i smell a secret
i smelled wrong okay let's just fight
the boss already because that's all i'm
good for
oh i can fly when can i fly since when
could i fly
also i still have the basic attack but
it seems to be a little beefier now
if i'm not mistaken maybe i can't tell
maybe it is maybe it isn't
at least i can fly so that's that's a
thing that's the thing i can do
that's a plus that's a plus in my book
good
whoa hey whoo all right let's try this
come on you bastard the gate huh that's
all you got
you ain't nothing but a hound dog
what what is this oh come on
what are you kidding me one shot and i'm
done
this is the stupidest this is the worst
okay okay okay okay
just finish him off quickly thank you
quickly thank you quickly thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
yes yes
back in my day these guys suck this okay
mom's for underwear range up good
good good for me good good good for me
you know i i need i need special hobbies
and whatnot
oh no trapped in a chest that means in
one of these chests there's randomly
just a kid here
thank you for giving me an extra heart i
guess
no i don't know i just want to go
home i just want to go home pay the
price
that didn't hurt at all do i just wander
over traps now no
no no
nothing okay i really okay that hurt me
why did that hurt me on the way in
but not on the way out or the whatever
you know what i meant
these guys are gonna be a problem aren't
they they're gonna turn into floating
heads after they get done
okay well then
uh all right okay okay
okay this is where you send me okay
all right a-hole
son of a bunker nutter you still got a
key
that's good this goddamn brain is gonna
be the death of me
this goddamn brain is gonna be what
stops me from progressing in this world
what is that
touch fuzzy get dizzy what does that
mean what do you mean
i don't know what you mean by that
i gotta kill that guy somebody's gotta
open up to me open up your dingus
open up your wimbly bastard open up
open up oh come on you open up when i'm
not able to hit you
the binding of isaac you gave me items
that i do not like
there we go done and done finally and
gold
gold what does that star mean
what does that star mean does that mean
there's something in here
there's a star it's a star mean
okay whoa wait whoa
okay all right that's it then get lots
more bombs
test out that wall because why not
go here okay this is a mistake i
shouldn't have gone in some of these
rooms
it's just a death trap waiting to happen
does the blood matter
does the blood are going to hurt me i
guess not okay
somebody thump i don't have that many
hearts screw you
still don't know what my special item in
the corner does
i could have floated around it frick
what did that do with that too
i don't know what that did what is that
little brimstone i know this the grumps
had this guy
it goes it doesn't hurt me thankfully
i thought it did for them wait
ow okay
oh they port okay that's what i was
missing
so many cool items too bad i only have
one gash darren hart
well i guess we're done here ah
are we am i not supposed to kill those i
am supposed to kill those okay good
thing these
poops are corny that's a nice touch
there's a goddamn boss there's a ding
damn
boss
okay they're done the guy's useless
i've got such an entourage only one of
one or two of them i actually like
whoa no no you don't no no i don't like
this
i don't like this
i don't like this it's hard to control
where my guys are shooting
okay boom thank you brainy for once
come on with this baloney
there we go all right look
up that's good oh i didn't even oh oh
god it's the final boss
i'm gonna die aren't i
what i'm dead i hate
everything isaac
rub my cankles
it's that brain the brain screwed me
over didn't it
the brain did brain dead brain dude
isaac isaac
okay well all right well i thought i was
dead i thought i was done so
okay now i'm done so now i'm done this
is gonna this is gonna this is gonna be
great this is gonna be
this is gonna be really really really
great this is gonna be great have i
mentioned how great this is gonna be
it's gonna be just
the greatest ever ever ever ever in the
history of ever i can't pay attention to
this stuff stuff
isaac isaac isaac
aye dick oh boy
oh god damn it come on
i got to be perfect on this you're
making me be perfect on this i hate you
isaac god if you screw me over at the
last year
i'm just never gonna be able to finish
this game this is isaac
isaac okay
god i gotta i gotta i gotta be moving
all the time
but the only problem is that's going to
kill me i just got i got to stay mobile
because otherwise it's just going to do
me in
i dick okay i was moving i was trying
i am not having a good time
not having a good time
okay okay
okay well i don't know how i didn't get
hit by that i was
thought it was gotten me for sure isaac
what
isaac what
what whoa hey whoa lady
what can you tell me what you want
what you really okay a goddamn brain
the freaking brain how do i get rid of
the brain get rid of the brain
i don't want the brain
i don't want the brain i just don't want
the brain
i don't want the brain
i really don't want the brain guys i
don't understand how much i don't want
the brain
isak
okay almost got me there i gotta pay
attention to the shadow i just noticed
that a shadow like pops up
okay pay attention pay attention brain's
gonna come up any second now i gotta
worry about my own mechanic that's gonna
kill me
that's how bad i am oh god brain's out
brains out brain's up
it's killing brain blow up away from me
rain i swear to god
oh brain you freaking [ __ ]
god such a dick
ah hey the brain
kind of messed up mechanic is it where
you get hurt by your own stupid piece of
crap
but why doesn't it just blow up
predictably okay
all right that was that was something
else someone else got me i was worried
about the brain
it's my last shot apparently mother of
frickin
fracker frick
me goose
i can't believe it
hi zach
isaac what whoa
okay just just brain do not screw me
over on this
whoa brain you almost got me
okay all right almost there let's give
it the guy
whoa hey whoa
what go oh god oh god oh god get that
heart oh my god
okay come on yes
yes one heart
just as he accepted his fate god
intervened sending an angel down from
above to stop his mother's hand
and just like that it was over
yay
that was really rough but i did it okay
so that may seem like the ending
it's not really because there's a lot
more to this game than may be
known there's tons and tons of stuff if
you want to play this game you probably
already heard about it it's a great game
it was a lot of fun
that was quite a challenge the items
that i got actually worked against me
but i conquered and succeeded no matter
what so go me
thanks again everybody for watching i
gotta end it here but you can check out
other awesome games that i played in the
description down there below or in the
annotation over there
i played a ton of stuff you might find
something new that you haven't seen
before
thanks again everybody and as always i
will see
you in the next video
oh my god
dude dude